Laura Ingram is just furious that more people
haven't died from Corona virus, and we knew
that this would start happening.
I just didn't think it would happen so quickly.
This is a version of what I called the anti-vax
or conundrum.
I'm not saying Laura Ingram is an anti vaccine,
but this is the anti-vax or conundrum and
falling for it or deliberately perpetuating
it depends on your view.
But this is what Laura Ingram is doing on
her show.
She is putting out this fury, this anger that
in the end fewer people are going to die from
Corona virus.
Then the number that might have died had we
not taken it seriously.
Let's watch the clip and then I'll explain
what I mean by the anti-vaccine conundrum.
And by the way, another cost of these lame
panic inducing models, it looks like we really
didn't need the USS Mercy or the USS Comfort
in New York or Los Angeles.
Americans should be furious about this.
Of course, the men, the women in these ships
that are doing their patriotic duty, they're
amazing.
The commanders, amazing.
But this is a lot of money that we're spending
on a response that was based again on faulty
numbers.
Now, long before the government figured out
that these fancy covered 19 models were wrong.
My own little, teeny little band of medical
advisers and a few statisticians that are
a lot smarter than I am insisted that they
had also crunched the numbers.
And this is weeks ago, they were making decisions.
The people in charge, based on what my team
said, were wildly incorrect assumptions and
ultimately incomplete data.
So there is a ton here.
The whole point of a model is what would happen
if we don't change what we're doing right
now.
So the numbers aren't faulty.
It's that we control the outcome by our actions.
You would think someone who subscribes to
the idea of personal responsibility would
understand.
Our actions determine our future.
So when the models said before we shut anything
down based on the contagion rate and the death
rate and viral spread, this is pointing to
1.5 to 2.2 million people could die in the
United States.
Or maybe the number is three hundred thousand
five hundred thousand depending on which model
you looked at.
We then did stuff right, like shutting things
down, reducing contagion, reducing spread,
which then modifies the curve, changes the
trajectory.
And we have new data with which we make a
new set of projections.
And of
course, the projected deaths decrease the
more stuff that we do.
So people have been sitting at home for a
month, many of us five weeks, the ones of
us that took this seriously right away and
had a responsible governor, obviously that
will improve the projections and decrease
the death toll.
She is visibly mad that more people haven't
died, which in her mind means everything we've
been doing was pointless.
And this is the anti-vax or conundrum.
Anti-vaxxers will often say measles vaccine.
Measles is so rare we don't need a vaccine.
The reason measles is rare is because we've
had a good vaccine for a long time now.
If we didn't have it, more people would get
measles.
Having it makes people think we don't really
need it.
Anti-vaxxers seem not to understand this,
or at least pretend not to.
Lots of corona virus contrarians, as they
are sometimes called, appear not to understand
that we bend the curve.
The curve doesn't have unlimited power.
It is not omnipotent.
We shape it by what we do.
We should be glad we had more resources deployed
than necessary.
And this is why the health care system needs
to be outside of the for profit system.
In the for profit system.
Being proactive and being ahead of things,
being prepared is not rewarded.
It actually doesn't even fit with health care
as a for profit entity in the mind of someone
like Laura Ingram.
A hospital ship that didn't end up being used
or ventilators that we didn't end up needing.
That's a sign of failure, because if you consider
profit the primary goal of the health care
system, it has failed.
It deployed resources that weren't actually
needed.
It's a waste of money.
Now, if you believe that
the health care systems primary goal is to
keep people healthy, then when you hear, hey,
you know what, we were able to get more ventilators
than most states needed.
Not all, but most states needed.
Or we had a ship that ended up only being
used the tiny bit.
You're happy about that because the goal is
taking care of people, not making money.
So you say, hey, wow, we were more prepared
than the level of disease we ended up having.
That's a success.
When you believe the primary goal is profit
a ship you don't need or ventilators you don't
use are considered signs of failure.
That's why health care should be outside of
the for profit model.
These people at Fox News are sick.
Imagine being furious that we reduced the
death toll.